okay um I guess we can get started so as
Peter mentioned I'll be covering mainly
multimodal
models um and then some other stuff
which I will outline but yeah let's get
started
so uh I guess what are multimodal models
very broadly it's kind of
self-explanatory models that can
incorporate multiple modalities Um this
can there's like a lot of different
modalities available but the main ones
that people generally work on right now
are to images and video which are very
similar if you count it as like images
and videos are just like the vision
modality um there's text and audio and
there could be more if you do robotics
there could be other like sensory data
there could be like touch like tactile
sensory um but these are the predominant
ones that are currently used right now I
think most mostly because it's just due
to the availability of data that you can
actually just scrape online um like if
you scrape YouTube you'll have video and
audio and you could get text if you do
labeling uh text is easy to scrape and
images are also pretty easy to scrape
and in the end when we learn these
multimodel models there are some
outcomes that we would like uh the first
is we would obviously want to achieve
some sort of multimodel understanding um
where you can like understand both
images and text and learn how they like
interplate together and then the second
one which is a little bit more difficult
um is that we want to achieve better un
modal understanding so like if I have
image data and Text data and I TR train
jointly on both these two modalities can
I have a better understanding of just
Language by itself or just images by
itself and this is a brief outline of
the different models I'll be talking
about most of these will just be uh I
guess I'll be broadly covering the
different kinds of architectures and
types of models that people have done
and like kind of like how they're
trained there won't be anything new in
terms of like generative models uh like
like we basically covered everything
most of these are autoaggressive
sometimes there's diffusion those are
probably the main two um so we most
mostly focus on like uh what kinds of
models they are how they're structured
and also like what capabilities that
we're seeing with current like Large
Scale Models like uh like gp4 or Gemini
and stuff that they can do and where
they might fail and then so that's the
first four of the different kinds of
models that I've kind of like separated
um and the last one that I'll just be
talking about some parallelization in
Transformers this is kind of related to
um a part of lecture that we were
supposed to cover in the llm lecture
that we didn't get time to but so we
moved it here and it's a pretty good um
ending in terms of basically all these
models we're covering are essentially
Transformers in some form and the last
part is just some practical applications
of how you actually parallelize it if
you have like a thousand devices how do
you train on that um so it could be very
useful okay so the first part is on
bidirectional models which bidirectional
in this in this sense that it's just
like let's say not a causal Transformer
so clip will just categorize as like by
directional model uh well I guess
technically the the text encoder is
causal but um it's not it's not that's
not really used in any way right now um
and yeah so the so there's been so we
covered clip already I think Peter
covered it in like the self-supervised
or like one of the lectures before so I
won't go into how that works but it is a
contrastive objective and you learn an
image and text encoder and you can use
clip to do some pretty cool things the
original paper did image classification
which is I think the easiest application
where you can just take an image and
then you can compute its clip score
alignment with different uh classes and
then classify according to the class of
the highest alignment uh
one one neat thing about this
classification that you can actually
achieve with these text image models in
comparison to let's say image only so
let's say if you did like Sim clear or
something on um on imag net and then you
did like a linear probe or something or
you you train a classifier from that
pre-trained backbone to classify imag
net something that I I don't have the
plot here but something that was
interesting that kind of clip showed
Improvement on was it was a lot more
robust
um than the image only ones in terms of
like how robust it is to certain like
distribution changes in the in images
compared to image only
ones so that's like potentially one
benefit of like combining text and
images the other one which they was
explored I believe in the dolly paper
originally was they used the clips score
as a ranker so because essentially you
have your image and you have your text
and then you can compute how aligned
these these two elements are and for
what they did was they just would
generate let's say if you had like a
text caption and you can generate like
maybe like 10 or 100 images um and then
if you want to choose one pair from that
you can just compute the clip scores for
all 100 Pairs and then choose the one
that has the highest alignment which
usually works pretty
well this was some work from uh a j that
used to be in our lab it was called it
was like kind of one of
the original like text to 3D papers
and it's called dream Fields this was in
its beginning phases so it wasn't like
you know super like crystal clear but it
showed like some pretty cool
capabilities in transferring like what
clip understands about language into
generating 3D and what this essentially
did was you like initialize like a Nerf
a Nerf parameters and then you just
optimize your Nerf parameters to um to
align with a high clip score with a
given text caption so if the text
caption was like like an armchair in the
shape of AOC Auto then you would start
with an like random parameters you would
use a Nerf to render and then you would
take like a you you render like an image
of it like an an image of the 3D object
and then you would feed that through the
the clip image encoder and compute the
clip score and then you would back
propagate back to the to update the the
Nerf parameters there there's some more
stuff like Nerf specific things to try
to encourage it to generate image like
objects things to encourage like the
occupancy of um like the resulting 3D
structure but at its core it's
essentially just optimizing
clip and this was like in the very
beginnings of like text to image stuff
where this was before text to image
models or text to image generation
models existed and this was another way
to generate an image quote unquote
generate from a text caption uh where
they would do something kind of neat is
that they would just essentially just
take a VQ Gan embedding space um and
then they they would start with like a
random like latent they would feed it
through the VQ Gan decoder um and then
like take some crops and feed those
crops into the the clip the clip image
encoder and then have it aligned with
some some like some like user specified
text caption and and you can generate
some kind of like weird images and then
essentially this is very similar to
dream Fields where you're optimizing
like per data point so this is you're
you're doing like like gradient descent
or gradient Ascent on the um on like the
VQ Gan latent embed itself so there's no
like neural nut that's being trained
here it's just using all pre-trained
models um and you get like some weird
things like it's very like there's a lot
of weird artifacts you can see a lot of
like repetitive patterns um mostly
because it's not because you're
optimizing eclip score which can have
like some really weird areas in like the
image space that have really high
alignment but you can get some kind of
cool cool stuff um and then after that
you can also even do clip guidance for
for diffusion models and that tends to
work well when you actually have a model
that actually can generate an image
um but yeah this is like stuff you can
use with clip in terms of like image
Generation Um why do I have the same
slide all right let's skip that
okay and then there's a lot of other
ones in other domains that people have
actually used um the it it's used first
bullet point it's used as a backbone
very commonly if you take uh some
pre-train if you want to train like a
vision language model um you generally
take like a pre-trained LM that
understands text and a pre-trained like
some sort of pre-ra image encoder that
can understand vision and then you kind
of combine them and then clip is a very
common uh like Vision encoder that's
used as like a pre-trained
backbone uh and yeah for representations
also kind of as like a pre-trained
backbone for like stable diffusion they
cross they cross attend on the on the
text embeddings for um for like on the
text encodings of the the clip text
encoder to condition on language and
then the last one is is one paper where
they it's called cliport which is a
paper where
they is in the context of Robotics of
where they kind of like uh train like a
robotic policy that could do different
tasks um with some like fancy
architecture design but at its core it
was initialized from the the image
encoder for clip and so what that kind
of allowed you to do is you could train
you can learn a policy to do stuff on
like a subset of objects so you can ask
it to pick up like a red block or like a
teddy bear and then um it could
generalize to different objects or
different colors or or stuff that is
still in in distribution of clip but
wasn't necessarily trained um in the
downstream
policy yeah and the last point is kind
of alludes to that is that for most
cases you can like have like some small
amount of fine tuning data for a
specific task you want to solve and if
you fine tune with clip then it could
hopefully like generalize to to
different unseen visual concepts um that
we're not seeing during fine
tuning
yes
um so I I guess clip is very useful
something contents talk like let's say
for cliport it's very useful because um
there's a language component so you have
a task you specify uh put the red block
on the green bowl and um and now it can
generalize to a different task that was
like put the the teddy bear in the brown
box or something uh potentially uh
so in that sense clip is probably the
main use for like text to image encoder
that can generalize things um but I'm
not sure about like like image only
probably wouldn't be able to do that
well because you would have to learn the
text understanding from scratch
essentially and okay so this was another
paper called M3 AE
and the general way this works is fairly
straightforward if you're familiar with
how Mae works is Mae is essentially this
top half so you have your image and then
you you mask it out
uh you you feed in the unmasked uh or
you feed in the yeah the unmasked
patches through your encoder and then
you try to decode the rest the original
image uh m3e was just that plus text as
well so it's like a ma plus like Bert I
guess where you also mask out the
language tokens same architecture style
but now your input to the encoder just
concatenated uh unmasked image and
unmasked text tokens and then you try to
decode the entire like text image pair
modality there and then in this case you
could also so in this case you could do
it with text image pairs uh you could
also do it with um like image only data
in that case the text would be fully
masked out you could use text only data
in that case the images would be fully
masked out um so you can use use it for
any combination of those modalities but
I believe this was mainly trained on
text image
data yeah so if you're
um trying to
remember I I don't remember off the top
of my head it it could be they add
position codings first here and then
when it's um the are selected it it
keeps like its relative position in the
in the original image but I I don't
remember exactly I have to see the
code is there another
question okay and one neat finding about
M3 AE so this was compared to Mee so Mae
just train on only images let's say yeah
only images and M M3 AE trained on both
the image and text and this was the
linear probe accuracy I think on
probably imag net imag net um but you do
see a a very large boost in in like the
the quality let's say the quality of the
representation as as a function of how
how good it is um as like a linear probe
most likely because um the Capt like the
the the labels or the targets for imag
net are also are all very like like more
language like in the sense of like it's
like a do like a type of dog or a type
of cat or a car or a truck uh which may
have facilitated just better
representations for for this kind of
thing and with fine tuning there's less
of a gap because now you can update all
all the parameters but there's still
some improvement especially
um uh with you can get away with fine
tuning less um like like fewer like a
smaller part of the network to get
pretty good
performance
yeah sorry
yeah
yeah and these are some visualizations
of I believe essentially visualizing
like the you can see that the green uh
like the the green square there is uh
what what parts of the text that green
square token is attending to so focuses
on the strawberries maybe too saturated
but that
says well it says straw and then
might be bar that looks too long to be
berries but but but yeah something like
that um and then same thing for that
thing over there can't see the oh okay
so straw and then pound sign pound
signed berries I I don't know why had
those
um and then the last oh the last one was
a roof leaking and it was like a picture
of like the the leak and it focuses on
those those parts of the word or the
sentence and this is also a ization of
just like the the plots of like the
representations where it's far better
clustered for the m3a which had like
text a supervision compared to Mae which
you can kind of there are some like
clusters but it's much more scattered
than
M3
yeah oh I uh oh yeah yeah maybe yeah
yeah that's that seems feasible yeah
likely cool okay so those are the like
that class of like bidirectional
multimodel models um now I'll be
covering just different kinds of more I
guess more Transformer Focus models
encoder decoder decoder only in like
multi mod Generation Um but the first
one would be kind of like encoder
decoder style
models um the first one is is flamingo
so what this one does is so that the
first thing they do is they leverage a
pre-trained language model so pre-ra LM
on just pure Text data and then the
question is how can you is like now I
wanted to be able to understand images
so it's like how do you feed in in
conditional images and Flamingo is one
of the slightly more complicated
architectural choices but the the way it
works is essentially you have like your
your end layers of your language model
so on the right there you see like first
LM block and LM block and then in
between all of them you essentially
insert um what they call this G gated
cross detention plus dense layer it's
it's it's like another gated Transformer
block which you can then condition on
images and the way they can images is
they just have like a vision
encoder um for exactly what it was it
might have been some reset and then like
a resonant that's pre-trained on like
like image classification or some self
supervisor objective it could be
whatever and they used a perceiver
resampler which I'm not sure if we
covered perceiver in this class but at
its core it it's just
a it's just like a Transformer like
architecture that will convert like any
like variable Siz uh tokens so for
example this Vision encoder could
potentially output different like size
tokens depending on the input resolution
of the image if there like a larger
resolution it could output more more
tokens uh but the perceiver would just
convert it process it so it's like it it
computes an encoding that is a constant
I think in this case it was 64 tokens
per
image and and the way they condition on
it is they have this gate across
attenion dense layer which is similar to
a standard uh self attention layer so
they have but instead of self attention
it's cross attention so they cross
attend um where the the query is like
your the hidden states of your
Transformer and then the key values is
what you're cross attending to which is
in this case is like the
images or the images that you condition
on and then after that it's the standard
feat forward layer of like a standard
Transformer block and the one different
thing why they call it gated as well is
because they add 10h gating in front of
each each of the attention and and feed
forward where the main purpose of this
is that at
initialization um the the gate will be
zero so when you just start training the
the model will be behave identically to
like the original language model it was
initialized from and then as you train
it will learn how to incorporate um like
the we will probably go like like go
like deviate away from zero as it learns
how to incorporate the image information
to help predict the the tech the text
that it needs to predict so so so one
thing about this model and a lot of
models I'll be talking about is that
these models still only generate text
but just learn how to condition on
images so they can't generate images
they only can generate
text and this is an example of some of
the the capabilities they showed for
Flamingo so this is kind of like um like
something kind of like in context
learning or like task specification so
it's like an image this is a chinella
this is a Sheba and then it's asking you
to like to to fill out the red like like
it's it's like providing the first two
examples as an example of like what the
task is and then ask you um to to solve
the the new task
that it's um like the novel image it is
um and other stuff like for different
formatting so what's the title of this
where is this painting stuff like that
for QA um and this is like implicit like
a kind of like a OCR task you're giving
examples of OCR for reading signs then
you ask it to to solve a new one um
which is a new
sign some other cool things uh top one
is kind of I I guess it's like kind of
like video understanding if you just
concatenate like a sequence of frames in
this case you probably can't add too
many frames but you can ask a question
about like this video and then they can
try to answer it you can have
conversational things about an image and
um yeah you can have multiple questions
about some image asking about certain
aspects of it and other
stuff and these are the quantitative
results they had um
pretty much like pretty far
outperforming some previous like zero
few shot State algorithms the um the
dash line was is the state-of-the-art
for like a fine tuned model like a kind
of like benchmarks Benchmark specific
fine tuned model uh so for some of them
it was still underperforming zero shot
to like the actual like fine tune State
ofth art and for some of the other tasks
it was outperforming it and on the right
here it was generally one of the
first studies I guess on like the
scalability and capabilities of these
models and what happens as you scale
which as you can kind of expect the
model gets better and better as you
scale and this was mostly scaling the
llm part of the
network okay um this is another kind of
this is closer to a more formal like
encoder decoder Style Network that we
see uh called poly
so pretty straightforward architecture
is you just have your image you have a
vision Transformer which will basically
essentially tokenize the image into like
uh 256 tokens and then you would
concatenate it with the language edings
and feed it through the Transformer
encoder um and that would output the
representation for essentially the
question so so usually the input would
be like some question uh plus an image
and then the decoder would answer the te
or answer the question or to generate
text condition on the encoder output so
this is very similar to like the
original original attention is all you
need like encod or decoder architecture
but just incorporating
images and this one they had like a
similar similar Trend as Flamingo where
like the more scale you have the better
and this they also did scale the
division component as well you can see
like vit G vit G and v e
um and then another huge benefit which
we'll see
like quite frequently in all these
Future Works is that like if you want to
get a good performance Boost from a
model like you you you can scale your
model but another option is also to to
scale your like the resolution of the
image that you're inputting which will
give you for some of these pretty large
boosts especially let's say like text
caps probably has a really large boost
in performance and that could be
understandable because it's mostly like
kind of like a OCR like document reading
potentially kind of t where um you need
like finer grained patches to understand
like the the text as like in pixel
form but yeah so so I guess in the end
if you want to improve performance there
could be multiple ways to add add flops
to your model essentially in the end
it's like if you add flops it will
probably be better and one way is to
increase the size of your model with
parameter count and the other way could
be to just add flops through higher
resolution because generally the higher
resolution you have the the more uh the
more tokens you have or the longer
sequence length your Transformer so as
you have more flops there as
well but with no change in paramet
count and after poly there were a few
other papers throughout last few years
so poly X um most I won't go too deep
into these but most of it was just like
better results through further scaling
um more tinkering with the training
schemes of like doing mixtures of
different like self-supervised
objectives and different like d like
they had a lot of different like kind of
like d noising tasks um
and like the the the language model
training um further trading with OCR
objectives on the vision encoder which I
think that was just essentially OCR
training um for like unim model for the
image encoder part and which did
transfer well to to better OCR and the
downstream model poly 3 um I think there
that goal was to basically build a
smaller model that was also very capable
so before they were using I think a text
encoder trained
on OCR plus some like jft like their
image classification like the the image
classification data set they have at
Google um but they S A sigp which does a
lot of large scale text image training
and they had other things of like a
better data mixture of what kind of like
OCR like high quality OCR data other
sorts of high quality data going to
higher resolutions this paper I believe
they did like
Progressive I think most of these papers
did like poly X and poly 3 both did it
but they do like Progressive training on
higher and higher resolutions um poly 3
they the like the largest resolution
they train on was like around like 1,000
by 1,000
images and and yeah so the end result
was pretty neat is that they had pretty
similar performance to poly X while
being around 10 times smaller so poly X
was like 55 billion and poly 3 is like
five
billion yeah
um I'm not entirely so I think in the
end
the I'm not 100% sure but I think what
ends up happening is that the the
encoder can um accept essentially
variable resolution but what happens is
you just have like more tokens as output
and then those and then so that the
downstream Transformer or as you train
the entire model it can accept like a
different sequence length
essentially cool that was the encoder
decoder uh decoder only is probably more
common especially in like the larger
Scale Models nowadays um this was one of
the first paper that exported us back I
don't know like three years ago called
Frozen and very simple idea so it's also
taken a pre-train language model uh in
this case you take your vision encoder
they Ed like a very simple like reset
reset encoder um even the language model
in that case in that time wasn't very
good this was just kind of like a proof
of concept kind of thing um they so they
have their text image data and they F
tune on it so in this case the image
followed by let's say the caption and
then everything is frozen except the div
Vision encoder which is fine-tuned and
the whole thing is is trained on on like
the next token prediction loss for for
language and these are some of the stuff
they do very similar to like let's say
Flamingo which is kind of around a
similar time of like doing
vqa
um like f shot like yeah in like few
shot tasks where you can specify um like
inter leave data inter leave data is
something that is more difficult to do
in the encoder decoder style models
because it's not clear how you would
structure the input for encoder decoder
um but for decoder only you can just
treat the sequence as like a continuous
stream of like tokens that you can
concatenate to so it's much easier to
have like these kinds of like task Tas
specifications if you want to mix images
and language
together and
after um after Frozen this was more
recent after let's say llama came out
from meta and then there were more like
instruct fine tun so vuna is an example
of a fine tune version of llama that was
designed to like follow language
instructions and so you can do a similar
thing if you want a similar model for
for images what you can do is these are
pretty close to concurrent Works Min gp4
and lava is that you can take your
vicuna based model which is essentially
llama um freeze it and then you can t
this with a vision encoder so mini GPT
uses this vit plus Q forer which is from
a paper called blip 2 and lava uses a
clip a clip image
coder and
then and then in between they have like
a single like projection layer that
basically Maps the dimensionality to the
input of like the the vicuna
Transformer
and in most cases in this case the only
thing you train is is like the the
projection layer and it actually works
pretty well in terms of like multimode
understanding and this is pretty cheap
because a lot of stuff is frozen and
very little is actually fine-tune
the the actual training scheme for lava
was a little bit more complicated than
mini gp4 they broke into two stages so
in the first stage you you just train on
a slightly larger set of like 600k text
image Pairs and you you freeze the
vision and language backbones and you
only train the projection layer so
that's like what mini gbd4 does and then
stage two what you can do is uh you have
like a lot more concentrated like high
quality instruct data like well curated
u a lot a lot smaller number where then
you can fine-tune the entire thing
except in this case they also just kept
the vision backbone still
frozen but the important thing was they
also just fine- tune the language model
itself which is which in general you
should be able to have a lot better
performance just because you're
fine-tuning a larger portion of the
model and these are some examples that
they had some pretty cool ones
so oh wait was this uh oh no so
let's let's skip
this okay that's fine
um yeah and then they had some future
they had like more iterations of this
work they had lava 1.5 which larger
resolution they saw better performance
they instead of like a linear projection
layer they just did an MLP and then
maybe like a two- layer MLP and then
they had just better instruct data with
just better vqa data OCR data stuff like
that to get better performance
and they had some benchmarking against
like some prior models here and in
general performs pretty strongly
especially like what I kind of see is
like for example this model here uh with
80 billion parameters still performs
like quite a bit worse than
lava so for most of these cases you can
actually get really strong performance
just by curating really good data
especially if you look at performance in
comparison to some of the other models
with the same number of parameters like
lava 1.5 with 7B versus some of the
other 7B models um and even against some
of the larger
models so in this case like size size
does help but then also like very high
quality data curation and careful
training can actually go a long
way and for lava 1.6 that they
released semi recently um they had like
a they the the main novelty here was a
different way to partition your input
image and the way they do it is
especially if you want to support really
large resolution images is that after a
certain point where your image
resolution is too large what they do is
they just tile your image into tiles of
like smaller resolution images and then
they encode those
separately and then they flatten and
concatenate everything as input uh and
then they also have
a like a kind of like a down sampled
representation version or where they
down sample it to the tile size and they
encode it as input as well so you both
have like this kind of like down sampled
information that has potentially more
higher level information about the image
and then they have like the really fine
GRE details of like the original high
resolution image which could be really
useful for like document understanding
where you have a lot of really small
characters and this was some of the mod
the benchmarks they had uh like the last
row called lava NEX this one they also
scale up to
34b and in general has pretty strong
performance as especially as an open
source model compared to some of the
other
ones even against some like the like for
Gemini and
jd4 yeah
um perhaps I I think it's mainly data
might not be an issue I think it's
mainly just like a way to add flops to
your model that can make it essentially
just like do more computation per image
that enables it to generally perform
better
datawise I mean you can always do more
like potentially even like unimodal
training on higher resolution images or
even multimodal training so I don't
think that's too much of an
issue and and usually I guess one other
point is that higher resolution there is
more information but it's also not like
significantly more information than like
a 256x 256 image or
something okay
um brief uh I guess like
guesswork characteriz that's what GPT 4V
is doing because I I think the the um
the lava 1.6 like tiling thing I
mentioned um was most I think they
mentioned in their blog post was it was
probably inspired by how jbd 4V
potentially does it they they don't say
anything about it but you can guess from
their pricing model um which if you if
you play around because they have this
Vision calculator here which basically
tells you this input resolution or for
this input resolution image how many
tokens it is um in this case it's like
255 tokens uh for this 512 x
512 and from that you can kind of infer
so if you use like the low resolution
one you you'll get 85 tokens and then
the full resolution 512 x 512 you get
255 which is probably like 85 low
resolution tokens plus like 170 um other
tokens or like higher resolution tokens
and then if you if you input any larger
image than 512 x 512 so like 513 by 513
what ends up happening is that um it
gets like a very similar tiled Behavior
so 513 by 513 would end up still being
four tiles because it rounds up to the
nearest 512 essentially so it kind of
process it as like a 1024 by 1024 image
and so this is very this is like very
similar to how lava 1.6 is done and is
probably how um GPT forv does something
kind of like this but all
hypothetical and in terms of
capabilities uh there aett pretty few I
guess category need category things that
they can do there's like the gp4 and
same thing with gpt3 and language models
is that you can kind of act as a
knowledge Bank in this case you have a
knowledge Bank of more visual
information so it knows it knows what a
penny is uh it knows like what the what
like this plant is and then maybe even
like more famous shots or or shots of
like a city with like famous landmarks
that it will know um where it's
located you can do
OCR there's this one that was on pretty
pop on Twitter I think when g54 VI came
back this really complicated no parking
sign uh basically a constraint
satisfication problem where you ask it
oh where can I actually or what time can
I actually Park um or can I park in it
right
now and then it's goal to try to
interpret all these all these weird
things and to figure out oh when I can
actually Park um and then other stuff of
like B GPD 4V they also had like some
like a pretty neat series of benchmarks
on like different different tests
different AP exams sat bar exam stuff
like that um it can also do that which
is a combination of like high level
reasoning of like and and like visual
understanding of of reading like certain
diagram certain text and then doing
processing to try to answer the
question this was not exactly the same
one that they showed in the original
demo but I think someone someone else
tried but you can also potentially even
have like a mock diagram and then ask it
to to Output code that follows the
diagram it's obviously not probably not
perfect and it's probably has a lot of
error or it can only do easy things but
pretty
cool pretty cool
capability at least to start
with um and yeah these are some examples
I believe from their like safety or
System card but they it's like not
perfect it does as as all of these
models do they do hallucinate so a lot
of these they can just sound very I mean
reading this even I don't know if it's
correct or not because I don't
understand like bio or chem um but in
these cases I I guess it is still wrong
if like an expert verifies or for these
cases about like scans of brain images
where it's it's sometimes wrong but also
sometimes right which is not very
desirable Behavior if you if you want to
be able to trust
it cool and so that was gp4 there's gini
1.5 which was essentially focused on
longer context models um again we don't
know what it is they mentioned some
stuff about
discret models maybe VQ plus coka um so
it could be some sort of like discrete
Auto encoder that was trained something
similar to Koka which Koka does a
combination of image captioning plus
text to image contrastive objective so
you can almost think of it as like part
of it it's just like a VQ version of
clip I
guess okay
um yeah so so mainly one thing is that
their embedding could be discret
I don't know I mean it is discreet and
then um it also probably had like some
sort of like text image like Supervision
in the auto encoders
training um and this was yeah so this
these are some of the initial results
they had this was focus on their like
their long context focus of their model
where they can process very long video
one minute to one hour and this is a
very classical like needle retrieval
problem it was very common at first in
in models where basically you insert
like some like you have like a document
of like a million tokens and then you
insert some random fact um or some
random number like let's say the the
magic number is like 178 362 and then
you ask it oh what is the magic number
and then so it's essentially like a
retrieval problem in like this long
document um they did a similar thing for
video I think they way the way they
constructed this one was you have like a
a 6 minute or 1 hour video and then in
like in like a subset of the frames in a
very narrow range like randomly in the
video you just in they inserted a like
kind of like an overlay caption of
saying oh the magic number is is
whatever um at different depths so so
dep is where the needle or the magic
numbers inserted and then the x or the x
axis here is just the length of the
video that it was trying to process and
retrieve from and in general I mean the
task is not too hard but uh still pretty
impressive that you can actually do this
pretty perfectly over really long
contexts and I think that one even went
up to yeah on the right when up to 10
hours is pretty
crazy and these are some like I guess
still out would categorize as retrieval
tasks but ones that make more sense or
ones that are more natural so this one
is you feeding like a video like a
40-minute video of this shlock Holes
movie and then you can ask it a question
so it's like was it tell me some of the
information about the piece of paper
that removed from the person's pocket
and the time code of the
moment and then it can process this
video and and find that exact moment and
time code as well so I imagine they
probably has some sort of like uh
fine-tuning data that was similar in
nature to this that they potentially
collected not sure if it would just work
well I guess you would have to have some
sort of fine tuning data no matter what
and the other one which is pretty cool
so this one was like a a visual
retrieval so they just someone drew like
a really you know just like a sketch of
like this uh like this water
tanker with water pouring out of it and
it was asking you to find this moment in
the video or in the movie and then it
can find like the visually correspondent
scene that looks very
similar which is pretty
cool and this is some more stuff on Long
context like more quantitative results
of
for some data for some benchmarks I
think 1 hour video QA is one of the ones
newly ones they created where um if
you're processing long videos so there
there's like multiple ways to process
long videos so for example if my video
model can only take in 16 frames then I
can technically process a 1 hour long
video if I take 16 frames like stride it
across that one hour it's just very
sparsely selected um but ideally in this
case the the more the more dense frames
that you can sample and process from uh
the more complex questions you can
answer or the more like Advanced
capabilities you can have or understand
about the video so in this case they
kind of at least for their first men Mar
they show like improving capability as
you had inputed more frames into the
model um and then for OS schema kind of
like saturated after a little bit those
are also much shorter videos as well
three
minutes okay that was decoder only
models so now now I will be talking
about quickly about multimodel
generation and the way I'm phrasing
multimodel generation is a lot of the
video a lot of like the models we talked
about in this entire class are usually
generating one modality they could be
conditioned on multiple modalities but
it's usually generating one so there's
like stable diffusion generates only
images from text um these video
generation models only generate video um
video poet is probably one exception
where they generate video audio
um but now it's the question is like can
we have a model that can like generate
any number of modalities so we can
generate both text and image or generate
image from text or text from image um
have a single model that that does all
of this
and this model I'll be briefly talking
about which was pretty neat it was
called Cod I guess any to any generation
and the the goal for this paper was we
have uh images videos language and audio
and can we generate any of these
modalities conditioned on any of those
modalities
so I feed it in an image and the text
caption I want to generate video
or image and audio and generate uh a
text caption or or or basically any of
these combinations of input and
output and I'll only briefly talk about
this if you're interested you can
probably read more about it or see the
examples they have on their site
um but the way they do this is so they
have like a lot of stages of training
and the first thing they do is they
learn a joint embedding space that
basically they the goal is to learn a
single embedding space um where all of
these modalities um are aligned so one
example of that is clip so clip is a
text image model that learns a joint
embedding space for text and images that
is is like more or less aligned to be
the
same and almost sometimes like
interchangeable to some extent um but in
this case we want to learn one for
multiple modalities and the way they
this the way in this paper they did it
was a pretty simple approach um that has
some pros and cons but they just had
everything bridged to text because it's
moderately easy to find like X modality
plus text so they have like text and
video so they learn like a clip thing
for text and video um I I think the
training process was they basically just
freeze the the or they they train the
text encoder once and then they freeze
it for all the other ones and then align
to it um and then they use like text to
image data to learn the image encoder
text to audio data to learn um the audio
encoder all of which basically image
like these data sets kind of exist
already so you can just download them
and use them and and then they I guess
like stage one part two is they then
just train this um um they they train
individual generation models so they
train like a vision model condition on
text an audio model condition on text um
and so
on and then stage two gets a little bit
more complicated where basically because
the goal is you want to be able to
condition on not just text but also
audio or video or something but it's a
lot easier to manage now once you have
like this aligned Lan space since all
all of the representations are are are
very similar to similar to each other
when they like they have the same
meaning
so so so they basically essentially what
they have here is I won't go too deep
into it is that they they have some
extra fine tuning in these models to
incorporate the conditioning of the
other modalities and then in this case
there is like a predefined alignment
here because in this case you can see
it's like a frozen Vision encoder
whereas before you used the Frozen text
encoder but in this case since the
vision and text are kind of aligned
those vectors are kind of like
interchangeable or you can interpolate
between them and it will more or less
it'll more or less work it's not like
exactly align but they it's good enough
that you can kind of just interchange
them and then you can use this fact to
be able to condition on multiple things
when you
generate okay um and then and then
there's like another set of works that
are is a little bit more simpler the
these focus on mainly just
image generation and um image captioning
so you can do you can feed in text to
generate image or you can feed an image
to also answer questions
about and the way they do this is
similar to the different kinds of like
multimod models we've seen before kind
of like lava or mini gp4 where you have
like your clip encoder of the image that
you can feed in as tokens concatenate
with text and then now in addition to
the next token prediction of like the
language what you have on the on the
bottom there is you have essentially a
regression so it will it will regress
the uh the clip embeddings for the image
that it wants to generate now the output
of that when you do regression on like
this kind of like very like on like like
it's a very complex distribution in the
end it'll kind of regress to the mean so
it won't produce very good it won't like
correspond to very good images uh so
what they additionally fine-tune is like
a fine-tune version of stable diffusion
that will condition on on like the the
output lat from the regression and then
to generate like a more higher quality
image and so that's what emu does the
Lait the other one they instead of doing
a regression they they they quantize the
clip embeddings and then they do like a
like an autoaggressive prediction and
they they they still have because in
this sense they're using the clip
embeddings and the one the one thing
about clip embeddings that not ideal for
a generation is that clip is kind of
like a lossy encoder so you you won't
like you you won't be able to preser it
doesn't preserve everything about the
original image so for example if I took
the the clip encoder I froze it and then
I try I try to train a decoder on those
clip embeddings to try to reconstruct
the original image it it it won't be
like perfect it it will look like the
like maybe like a blurry version of the
image but it won't be really high
quality so they they still use like a
like a stronger decoder to to model that
Randomness in a sense to model the
information that is lost from the clip
encoder and oh yeah and and and these
are the different tasks that they had so
it can basically do any sort of like
image to text or text to image task so
doing some sort of like captioning you
can do some sort of vqa stuff you can
also in the end generate images and in
the end you have this model that can do
both of these things and then how you
actually want to elicit these responses
in terms of oh how does the model know
when to generate images how does it know
when to generate text that's all more or
less just done through fine tuning of
like the type of like the type of
fine-tuning data you
curate uh
where you have like potentially like
certain phrases or or it tries to learn
from this fine tuning data when it
should be generating image versus when
it should be generating text
this is the video version of
Lait um very similar in structure where
they have um they still concatenate
Visual and text tokens together they
just have a fancier Vision encoder they
have like the the key frames from like
an mp4 and then MP4 also has some motion
Vector information kind of like Optical
flow that then like
quantize uh but the way you generate a
video is still just like like
autoaggressive next token prediction on
these discret
latents and then and then they also
learn like another decoder on top of it
fine tune from like stable video
diffusion and this is some work that we
did recently in our lab which is just a
simpler Incarnation
um essentially instead of using clip
latents which are lossy we just use a VQ
Gan and just concatenate image tokens
together and then um and then during
training if you have like a bunch of
text image or text video data you can
like swap the order of the text tokens
and in and vision tokens because then
sometimes it be doing image generation
sometimes doing image captioning um and
then during fine tuning for chat
fine-tuning you can then basically
design data around to encourage certain
behaviors cool
yeah I think um well I guess in the end
the the ultimate challenge is is that a
lot of these models still have issues in
terms of they hallucinate they have like
like there are errors in visual
understanding especially video
understanding stuff like that like video
understanding there's like a lot of a
lot more work to do in terms of
understanding hierarchically how how a
movie operates uh what's happening in
this movie stuff like that that I think
there's still a lot of work to do in in
terms of like this kind of understanding
um